la séance est ouverte
le compte rendu analytique de la
précédente séance a été distribuée nous
n'avons pas reçu d'observation
je n'en vois pas le procès-verbal est
donc adopté sous les réserves d'usage
madame la Première ministre mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues l'ordre du jour appelle les
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
notre séance s'est retransmise en
direction publique Sénat et sur notre
site au nom du bureau j'appelle chacun
d'entre vous a observé au cours de nos
échanges le respect qu'il s'agisse du
respect des uns et des autres ou celui
du temps de parole je vais donner
immédiatement la parole au président
Patrick canaire pour le groupe
socialiste écologiste et républicain
[Applaudissements]
madame la Première ministre
ils avaient 23 ans ils sont morts pendus
exécutés en public pour l'un d'entre eux
par le régime des Mola iranien pour
crime de guerre contre Dieu
ils avaient un nom morcen secharie et
Maggie de résa arnava alors mémoire
j'aimerais que le Sénat respecte
quelques instants de silence
nous pouvons craindre qu'il ne soit que
les premiers d'une longue liste en effet
le régime iranien a annoncé via une
justice expéditive avoir condamné neuf
autres personnes à la peine capitale
dans le cadre des manifestations
déclenchées par la mort de Marsa Amini
la répression s'abat aveugle violente
sanglante depuis le début de la
contestation plusieurs milliers de
personnes ont été arrêtées plusieurs
centaines sont mortes 400 viennent
d'être condamnés à des peines pouvant
aller jusqu'à 10 ans de prison les CI de
du régime veulent écraser un mouvement
populaire où les femmes sont en première
ligne ou l'émancipation et le but
femme vit liberté ce slogan est porteur
des espoirs d'un peuple nous devons être
à la hauteur de cet espoir le 10
novembre dernier ma collègue Margaret
Carlotti vous interpellé pour demander
que la France exige l'exclusion de
l'Iran de la Commission de la condition
de la femme à l'ONU malgré le retard je
suis heureux que votre gouvernement ait
fini par écouter cette juste
revendication cette exclusion est
actuellement en débat à New York
certes des sanctions étaient prises par
l'Union européenne certes les
condamnations internationales existent
mais sont-elles suffisantes devant
l'ampleur de la répression mes chers
collègues un baril de pétrole vaut-il
plus que le sang d'un manifestant aussi
ma question est simple alors que le
peuple iranien se bat pour les droits
humains comment la France peut-elle
l'aider comment la France peut-elle agir
au sein de l'Union européenne pour que
la répression cesse et que la jeunesse
iranienne est prise de liberté
remportent son combat de lumière contre
l'obscurantisme
pour vous répondre la parole est à
madame la Première ministre madame borne
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
Président Patrick
femme vit liberté ce slogan est né en
Iran mais il a très vite dépassé les
frontières ces trois mots sont des
symboles puissants et un appel à la
liberté
en Iran le régime déni leurs droits aux
femmes il est cible pour ce qu'elles
sont
l'oppression que subissent les femmes ne
date pas de la mort tragique de Massa à
mini elle s'incarne dans les lois du
pays port du voile obligatoire mariage
précoce dès la puberté interdiction de
l'avortement crime demeure en Iran
devant les tribunaux la parole la parole
d'une femme vaut la moitié de celle d'un
homme
contre la négation de ces droits humains
un mouvement de protestation est né qui
ne faiblit pas qui s'était tendu à toute
une partie de la jeunesse et se poursuit
depuis maintenant deux mois il se
poursuit malgré la répression violente
qui a fait plus de 500 morts dont des
dizaines d'enfants au moins 15000
personnes ont été arrêtées deux Iraniens
ont déjà été condamnés à mort et
exécutés à la suite de leur
participation aux manifestations il se
poursuit malgré l'emprisonnement de
journalistes toujours plus nombreux le
président de la République a eu
l'occasion de dire notre admiration
notre respect et notre soutien à celles
et ceux qui défendent les droits
fondamentaux en Iran qu'il ne soit
permis au nom du gouvernement de leur
rendre hommage de leur dire que nous
sommes avec eux
face à la gravité de la situation la
France n'est pas impassible nous
agissons monsieur le Président canard de
manière forte ferme et résolue avec nos
partenaires européens nous avons envoyé
lundi pour la quatrième fois un signal
puissant d'unité et de fermeté aux
autorités iraniennes nous avons encore
élargi la liste des personnes et entités
faisant l'objet de mesures restrictives
en y ajoutant 20 membres du régime ainsi
que la radio télévision iranienne irrib
nous prenons des sanctions
significatives gel désavoir interdiction
de pénétrer sur le territoire de l'Union
et interdiction de mettre des fonds ou
des ressources économiques à la
disposition des personnes et entités
concernées
notre ligne est claire nous mettrons
tout en oeuvre pour que le régime le
régime iranien sorte de sa logique de
répression nous avons ainsi adopté il y
a deux jours de nouvelles conclusions du
Conseil de l'Union européenne sur l'Iran
qui établissent un cadre d'action
européen d'une grande fermeté enfin nous
soutenons les aspirations démocratiques
du peuple iranien la ministre de
l'Europe et des Affaires étrangères
Catherine Colona a remis à remis samedi
avec son homologue allemande le prix
franco-allemand des droits de l'homme à
Massa Amini et aux femmes iraniennes ces
efforts nous les poursuivrons sans nous
laisser intimider le régime cible ne
ressortissants certains sont détenus
dans des conditions inacceptables nous
continuons à exiger leur libération ce
qui se trouve en Iran ou envisage de s'y
rendre s'exposent à des risques de
détention arbitraire je veux donc ici
renouveler mon appel à la plus grande
vigilance
monsieur le Président Kanner je le redis
la France est restera aux côtés de
toutes celles et tous ceux qui
combattent pour la liberté pour les
droits humains je vous remercie
monsieur le Président Keller
[Applaudissements]
chez le Président Madame ministre nous
avons ici au Sénat soutenu l'Arménie
nous avons ici au Sénat soutenu
l'Ukraine nous voulons aussi soutenir le
peuple iranien dans son combat pour la
liberté j'aimerais qu'un jour ce peuple
puisse faire sien ce beau poème de 1942
de Paul Eluard liberté j'écris ton nom
merci monsieur le président
je vais donner la parole à notre
collègue Eric gold pour le groupe du
Rassemblement démocratique et social
européen vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre malgré des efforts notables
pour le déploiement de la fibre il ne se
passe pas une semaine sans que les élus
locaux soient sollicités pour des
dysfonctionnements chantier technique
abandonné coupure fréquente liée au
réseau aérien travail bâclé sur les
raccordements refus d'installer le
cuivre dans une construction neuve qui
bénéficie pas encore de la fibre
abonnement prélevé sans que l'habitation
soit raccordée déception par rapport au
débit les motifs de semer contemplant en
général sont innombrables larsep vient
d'ailleurs de publier les résultats
d'une analyse de terrain qui confirme la
situation avec des défauts notamment sur
l'état des câblages et ce que certains
appellent des raccordements en plein de
nouilles constat partagé par la Vicat
présidé par notre collègue Patrick
chaise qui dénonce des opérateurs
faisant trop souvent appel au
sous-traitants sans vérifier la qualité
ni la pérennité des installations
15 à 20% des abonnés seraient ainsi
touchés par un dysfonctionnement
monsieur le ministre nous sommes encore
loin du 100% comme annoncé du territoire
couvert par la fibre en 2022 et les
chiffres du déploiement cachent
d'importants disparités territoriale
entraînant pour certaines ou pour
certains plutôt une double peine
en effet en parallèle de ce déploiement
souvent insatisfaisant le réseau cuivre
est progressivement abandonné et donc
mal entretenu y compris dans les
territoires qui n'ont toujours pas la
fibre et qui subissent des délais de
dépannage atteignant plusieurs mois des
territoires qui étaient déjà fragiles et
qui se trouvent davantage pénalisé par
cette situation avec des conséquences
potentiellement critiques je pense par
exemple à la téléassistance qui ne peut
fonctionner qu'avec un réseau efficient
monsieur le ministre j'aimerais donc
savoir comment l'État entend agir
vis-à-vis des opérateurs qui n'ont pas
tenu leurs engagements s'il est prévu de
mieux informer les élus comme une par
commune et de remettre à niveau le
service après-vente du réseau cuivre qui
continue de jouer un rôle essentiel dans
certains territoires je vous remercie
pour vous répondre la parole des
communistes délégués en charge la
transition numérique des
télécommunications Jean-Noël Barrault
vous avez la parole monsieur le ministre
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur gold je partage évidemment
votre constat qu'on concernant les
défauts de qualité dans le déploiement
de la fibre qui place nos concitoyens
parfois dans des situations intenables
elles sont le fruit de plusieurs
facteurs d'abord la rapidité du
déploiement de la fibre dans notre pays
en disant la France est devenue le pays
le plus avancé en matière de fibres avec
77% des locaux raccordables deuxièmement
l'existence de réseau de fibres
historiquement mal dimensionnés
notamment ceux qui ont été déployés
parmi les premiers il y a 10 ans enfin
au recours vous la citer un nombre trop
important de niveau de sous-traitance
même si cette pratique a largement
diminuée face à l'accroissement des
difficultés qui remontent de toutes
parts et en particulier de la part des
élus locaux le gouvernement et l'ARCEP
ont saisi la filière Télécom afin
qu'elle formule des engagements ces
engagements ont été pris fin septembre
il s'articule autour de trois axes
premier élément le renforcement de la
qualité des interventions avec une
certification des compétences minimales
requises pour les raccordements finaux
deuxièmement la transmission par les
opérateurs commerciaux de leur planning
d'intervention et le partage des
comptes-rendus d'intervention de manière
à ce que les les pannes éventuelles
puissent être secours au plus rapidement
enfin le troisième axe et la reprise des
infrastructures dégradées que ce soit au
niveau des points de mutualisation ou
des réseaux vieillissants ou mal
dimensionnés plusieurs opérateurs ont
déjà notifié leur plan de reprise de
1000 points de l'utilisation
correspondant à 450 000 locaux ce plan
le gouvernement veille à sa mise en
œuvre le contrôle en est en revient à
l'ARCEP et des points de suivi réguliers
sont effectués en présence des
associations d'élus pour autant le
déploiement de la fibre et le projet
d'arrêt de commercialisation du cuivre
ne doivent pas se traduire par une
baisse de qualité de service ou une
exclusion de certains de nos concitoyens
la qualité du doit être maintenu en
attendant sa fermeture technique l'État
ne transigera pas et sur ce point notre
message est clair pas de dépose du
cuivre tant qu'une solution fibre n'est
pas proposée aux usagers sachez monsieur
le sénateur que je veille
personnellement à ce que cette
transition s'accompagne par ailleurs des
garanties nécessaires de disponibilité
de qualité et d'abordabilité de service
pour tous nos concitoyens merci monsieur
le ministre je vais maintenant donner la
parole à notre collègue Paul Toussain
Parisi pour le groupe écologie
solidarité et territoire
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président mesdames messieurs
les ministres mes chers collègues ma
question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre de la transition écologique et
de la cohésion des territoires elle
porte sur un écosside annoncé que l'État
ne peut ignorer par l'ampleur de la
menace qu'il fait peser sur notre région
je parle du projet du Centre
d'enfouissement de yuccadio aux abords
immédiats du deuxième plus grand fleuve
de Corse le tavignac à nous classer zone
Natura 2000 et zone naturelle d'intérêt
écologique phonistique et fleuristique
ce projet fou c'est le stockage et
l'enfouissement de 120000 tonnes de
Terra miantifères et de 70 000 tonnes de
déchets ménagés par an sur 30 années un
affouillement des sols abyssal dans une
zone géologique instable les pieds dans
l'eau ou d'import glissement de terrain
ont déjà été observés
espèrent géologue hydrobiologiste
confirme et signe le risque majeur de
destruction de cette écosystème aux
conséquences dramat sur la santé humaine
et les générations à venir je
rappellerai ici que le tavigna irrigue
toute la plaine orientale ou une
agriculture diversifiée de qualité
labellisée est connu mondialement pour
sa production d'agrumes est un
inestimable réservoir de biodiversité au
cœur même duquel INRA et sirad abri d'un
précieux conservatoire génétique des
agrumes d'Europe et d'ailleurs mettre en
péril l'alimentation en eau potable
toute une région détruire le cœur
agricole de la Corse hypothéquer la
santé humaine des générations futures
voilà Monsieur le Ministre les enjeux
dont il est question un acte criminel en
devenir dont la scène se joue
aujourd'hui sous nos yeux depuis six ans
nous demandons une interdiction totale
de ce projet malgré un arrêté de refus
initial pris par le préfet à l'intérieur
en 2016 et les prescriptions du préfet
François ravier en 2019 pour minimiser
les risques du projet
le combat juridique continue alors ma
question est simple serez-vous au nom du
devoir supérieur de l'État à protéger la
vie à son écosystème être à nos côtés
pour interdire la logique mercantile qui
hypothèque notre territoire et sacrifie
la terre que demain nous l'aiderons à
nos enfants je vous remercie pour vos
réponses la parole est communiste de la
transition écologique la cohésion des
territoires sur Christophe Béchu vous
avez la parole monsieur le ministre
merci monsieur le Président enable les
sénatrices messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur je voudrais vous
remercier pour votre question vous
pointez du doigt et vous braquez les
projecteurs sur la situation très
complexe depuis 2015 de la Corse en
matière de gestion de déchets un tiers
des déchets qui sont produits sur l'île
sont triés orientés vers le continent
les deux tiers se soit 160000 tonnes
doit être traité localement or les deux
installations de stockage qui existent
ne peuvent permettre dans l'accueillir
que 100000 tonnes par an face à ça une
société oriente Environnement a demandé
en 2016 à pouvoir stocker le long du
fleuve d'Avignon sur un site qui
potentiellement présente des risques
d'affaissement un site de stockage le
préfet a donc refusé sauf que le
tribunal administratif a cassé ce refus
en 2020 le préfet a donc pris une
décision qui a consisté à limiter avec
la vie d'ineri c'est un stockage partiel
et en novembre 2022 le tribunal
administratif a exigé que nous donnions
une autorisation complète de stockage
ce sujet est évidemment problématique il
y a l'autorité de la chose jugée et il y
a ce que vous décrivez en terme de
risque pointé y compris par les
autorités préfectorales plus largement
c'est la question de la gestion des
déchets encore ce qui se pose j'aurais
dû il y a quelques jours accompagnés le
mini Gérald Darmanin à l'occasion d'un
déplacement encore pour les rencontrer
les élus puisque ce sujet fait partie de
l'agenda des discussions que nous avons
avec les élus insulaires c'est reporter
aux premières semaines de l'année 2023
je ne fuirai pas mes responsabilités
j'irai la rencontre des élus je soutiens
évidemment la position du préfet je
soutiens les inquiétudes qui sont
exprimées par les élus locaux je
soutiens les risques qui ont été pointés
par beaucoup d'acteurs il faut qu'on
arrive à trouver une solution compte
tenu de la décision du tribunal
administratif et des risques que vous
pointez nous allons nous y atteler dans
les prochaines semaines
merci la parole est à notre collègue
Daniel Chassain pour le groupe Les
Indépendants République et territoires
vous avez la parole
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre le coût de l'énergie est
multiplié par 4 ou 5 c'est la teneur des
courriers que nous continuons à recevoir
tous dans les entreprises en détresse
sur des territoires certes il y a eu des
évolutions sur le dispositif de soutien
de l'État aux entreprises mais cela ne
paraît pas suffisant pour un bonhomme
dentelle au-dessus de 10 salariés nous
créons des fermetures dans le futur la
solution réside dans l'augmentation de
notre production d'énergie et
diversification nos sources énergétiques
nous venons d'examiner un projet de loi
afin d'accélérer le déploiement de CNR
des ENR pour une filière nucléaire
d'avenir on devrait se prononcer sur une
nouvelle programmation pluriannuelle de
l'énergie
le 16
le 16 novembre dernier madame la
Première ministre a évoqué un travail
prochain dont l'objectif sera je cite de
relancer rapidement les investissements
dans les barrages sans nécessiter une
remise en concurrence qu'en est-il dans
de nombreux territoires notamment en
Corrèze nous avons un projet de station
de transfert d'énergie par pompage step
avec un pompage en heures creuse dans la
Dordogne rodena ce projet de stockage
malheureusement stagne depuis des
décennies il permettrait de répondre au
pic de consommation turbinant à la
demande et d'éviter de manquer
d'électricité et de réduire les coûts
mais voilà EDF n'est pas en position
d'investir dans ce projet en grande
partie à cause de l'ouverture à la
concurrence des concessions
hydroélectriques imposées par l'Europe
pourtant c'est le Ministre l'énergie
doit être plus que jamais une question
de souveraineté pour notre pays monsieur
le ministre
ces dossiers qu'en est-il des
discussions engagées avec Bruxelles à
quoi pouvons-nous nous attendre
concernant les demandes de prorogation
des concessions merci
pour vos réponses la parole est à
Monsieur Christophe Béchu ministre de la
transition écologique la cohésion des
territoires
monsieur le Président Mesdames les
sénatrices messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur Chassain
vous avez bien posé les termes du débat
l'hydroélectricité la première source
d'énergie renouvelable dans ce pays avec
26 gigawatts et nous pouvons nous
féliciter des investissements qui ont
été réalisés par nos grands anciens dans
ce domaine mais vous avez raison aussi
il y a à la fois une volonté
gouvernementale rappelée exprimée par la
première ministre et une situation qui
est complexe contenue de ces
perspectives d'ouverture à la
concurrence et plus encore du
précontentieux qui a été engagé par
l'Union européenne sur l'absence de mise
en concurrence pour le renouvellement
des concessions d'hydroélectricité la
volonté du gouvernement de faire en
sorte de favoriser des énergies
renouvelables et de nous appuyer sur
celles qui ont fait leur preuve comme
l'hydro-électricité est totale je veux
saluer le Sénat qui en votant l'article
16 coinquises de la loi d'accélération
sur les énergies renouvelables a
notamment valider un processus qui
devrait nous permettre de contourner
cette difficulté puisque cet article
prévoit que les dispositions sur les
investissements pour assurer la
pérennité d'un ouvrage hydroélectrique
puisse être réalisé sans mise en
concurrence c'est le chemin que vous
pouvez t'en suivre j’ajoute que vous
avez cité aussi celui dont nous avons
besoin EDF la nomination d'un nouveau
président directeur général la
discussion de sa feuille de route la
caractérisation d'une stratégie qui est
à la fois celle du gouvernement et celle
de l'entreprise avec la perspective de
la nationalisation nous permet d'avoir
un alignement d'astre pour pouvoir
relancer ce sujet la route est semée
d'embûches mais l'enjeu de la
souveraineté de retrouver la maîtrise de
notre énergie commande que nous
trouvions des solutions je sais votre
attachement à ce sujet vous l'avez
évoqué avec moi dès le tout début du
mois de juillet lors de notre première
rencontre je peux vous assurer que notre
détermination est totale pour dépasser
ses obstacles précontentieux et relancer
ce dont nous avons besoin une production
française d'énergie renouvelable qui
nous permettent de tenir le choc et
d'offrir à nos entreprises et à nos
ménages des tarifs qui soient
compétitifs
la parole est maintenant à notre
collègue Patrick chaise pour le groupe
les républicains
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues la crise énergétique nous
amène à revoir nos organisations
domestiques comme professionnel afin
d'adapter nos consommations aux
ressources disponibles
vous nous annoncez cependant depuis
quelques jours des phases de délestage
de réseau ces coupures locales limité
dans le temps impacteront l'ensemble des
usagers ménages entreprises services
publics les réseaux de communication
électronique qui ont pourtant prouvé
leur caractère indispensable durant les
phases de confinement seront également
touchés
je souhaite donc attirer l'attention du
Gouvernement sur le cas spécifique des
réseaux de téléphonie mobile qui a
chemine notamment les appels d'urgence
en effet en cas de coupure même
momentané les numéros d'urgence y
compris le 112 ne seront pas accessibles
sur des pas entiers de nos territoires
je pense notamment au secteur moins
dense qui se sont desservis que par un
seul pylone tout défaut d'alimentation
électrique entraînerait alors une
impossibilité d'accéder au Service les
antennes n'étant pas considérées comme
des équipements prioritaires
de surcroît les éléments les plus
structurants du réseau pourraient être
aussi concernés la coupure de certaines
antennes aura des répercussions sur le
réseau national les opérateurs
pourraient être par exemple dans
l'incapacité d'assurer des missions de
sécurité intérieure
c'est pourquoi Monsieur le Ministre ma
question est double quelle garantie
pouvez-vous nous donner sur
l'acheminement des numéros d'urgence
vers les centres de régulation en tout
temps et en tout point du territoire
envisagez-vous de donner un statut de
réseau essentiel au réseau de
communication je vous remercie
pour vos réponses dans la parole est
communiste délégué chargé de la
transition numérique des
télécommunications monsieur barreau
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur chaise
permettez-moi monsieur le sénateur de
saluer d'abord l'immense travail des
salariés d'EDF qui mettent notre pays
sur la bonne voie ainsi que l'esprit de
responsabilité des français puisque RTE
nous annonce une diminution de presque
10% de la consommation électrique la
semaine dernière par rapport aux années
précédentes dans notre pays la
continuité des appels d'urgence que vous
évoquez repose sur le 112 qui a
l'avantage d'être mutualisé entre tous
les opérateurs nous devrons depuis cet
été à limiter au maximum les
conséquences d'éventuelles délaissage
sur les réseaux de télécommunication et
donc sur ces appels d'urgence il s'agit
d'un travail inédit titanesque du fait
de la nature et des choix historiques
d'organisation des réseaux en France il
suppose de déterminer l'impact croisé
des
des points d'alimentation du réseau
électrique avec les 110 000 équipement
télécoms dont 80 000 antennes et 30 000
équipements structurants qui leur
permettent de communiquer entre elles je
rappelle par ailleurs que même en
l'absence de l'elystage les réseaux
télécom n'est pas infaillible et que
chaque antenne dans notre pays tombe en
panne pour raison technique ou en cas
d'intempéries en moyenne une fois par an
à la demande du gouvernement les
opérateurs ont ainsi déjà pris des
mesures importantes ils ont renforcé des
cet automne l'alimentation de plus de
1000 nœuds et coeurs de réseau en les
équipant de batterie supplémentaires je
veille à ce que ces batteries soient
testées désormais chaque mois ils ont
considérablement réduit par ailleurs les
délais de transmission de la carte de
couverture du 112 afin que le ministère
de l'Intérieur puisse déployer des
moyens de secours additionnels en cas de
besoin en complément je vais vous dire
qu'en cas de délestage nous demanderons
aux opérateurs de réquisitionner tous
les équipements mobiles disponibles
ainsi que les équipes d'astreintes afin
de renforcer la résilience du 112 nous
verrons également à ce que tous les
opérateurs effectuer des simulations
pour prioriser les antennes à préserver
pour renforcer la résilience du 112 sur
la balle du travail réaliser cet automne
par les préfets et enedis vous le voyez
monsieur le sénateur le gouvernement est
pleinement mobilisé pour garantir
l'accès au numéro d'urgence des Français
en cas de les stages mais aussi pour
garantir la résilience du réseau télécom
ces prochaines années
monsieur chaise
j'entends votre réponse monsieur le
ministre je ne dis pas à vos échanges
avec les opérateurs mais reconnaissez
qui sont un peu tardif d'autant que je
suis pas persuadé que le délestage soit
vraiment la solution plutôt que des
mesures punitives je pense que des
actions récompenses sur des tarifs par
exemple pourrait être plus vertueuse les
territoires ruraux vont être pénalisés
attention donc à ce que les zones
délestées ne soient pas une fois de plus
les zones délaissées
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à notre collègue Nathalie
Goulet pour le groupe de l'unionfanterie
le Parlement européen à la demande du
groupe Renaissance et donc de votre
gouvernement a obtenu le vote d'un
amendement qui fait état de sa
préoccupation au vu des subventions
versées aux associations liées aux
Frères musulmans qui pourraient être
mieux contrôlés ça pourrait être une
bonne nouvelle mais pourquoi
proposez-vous à Strasbourg ce que vous
refusez ici en effet avec notre groupe
nous dénonçons depuis longtemps ces
anomalies et je dois dire que le mot est
assez faible et notamment lors d'une
question d'actualité sur le même sujet
au gouvernement le 25 novembre 2021 sans
aucun résultat plus récemment le
gouvernement a retoqué plusieurs
amendements au PLF pour la troisième
année consécutive visant à contrôler les
financements des associations nous
parlons d'à peu près deux millions
d'euros
quand allez-vous être plus vigilant sur
ces financements il ne suffit pas de
s'indigner de la campagne du Conseil de
l'Europe pour la diversité en Europe
faisant figurer une jeune fille voilée
il aurait fallu faire en sorte que cette
campagne ne soit pas lancée cette
indignation a été véritablement efficace
si on en juge la fiche de la campagne de
l'UNICEF que j'ai là la journée de
l'enfant avec une jeune fille voilée
voilà très efficace c'est très
intéressant
donc ce préoccuper s'indigner condamné
n'est pas suffisant quand allez-vous
assécher les financements des Frères
musulmans leur interdire tout
financement public et les inscrire sur
la liste des organisations terroristes
je vous remercie
pour vous répondre
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à Madame Colonna ministre
de l'Europe des Affaires étrangères
mais ce Président Mesdames et Messieurs
les Sénateurs madame la sénatrice Goulet
la protection de l'institutions contre
les ingérences étrangères et nécessaires
à l'intégrité de nos démocratie cela
requiert en effet de la vigilance croyez
bien que le gouvernement est mobilisé et
actif pour que les institutions
européennes intègrent bien le risque de
telles ingérences quelles qu'elles
soient je dis bien quelle qu'elle soit
et défendent notre socle commun de
valeur avec Gérald Darmanin j'ai
personnellement et avec Laurence Boon à
mes côtés j'ai personnellement saisi à
ce sujet la Commission européenne et le
Haut représentant il y a plusieurs mois
et je l'ai fait à nouveau auprès de
Joseph Borel
mi-septembre c'est ma mémoire est bonne
nous continuerons donc madame la
sénatrice de pousser le sujet notamment
pour un suivi plus fin des activités des
associations financées par l'Union
européenne afin qu'aucune d'entre elles
ne peuvent sous influence des agendas à
rebours de nos objectifs d'intégration
d'émancipation citoyenne et d'égale
dignité entre les femmes et les hommes
l'inscription que vous proposez des
Frères musulmans sur la liste européenne
des organisations terroristes n'est pas
possible madame la sénatrice car cette
organisation ne répond à aucun des
critères fixés par les règles
européennes cela ne change rien
cependant à notre détermination à
préserver le bon fonctionnement de notre
démocratie française et européenne je
vous remercie
musulmans sur la liste des organisations
terroristes les États-Unis ils pensent
je pense qu'il faut exiger des réponses
de la commission vous savez très bien
que les milliers et les millions d'euros
qui circulent sont véhiculés par le
Qatar qui lui protège les Frères
musulmans vous savez très bien qu'il
gangrène notre République ils espionnent
nos boîtes nourrissent des signes tongs
je crois vraiment qu'il faut en finir
avec cette naïveté et très franchement
exigé de la Commission européenne des
réponses et le minimum que nous
puissions bander
la parole est à notre collègue
Eric Bocquet pour le groupe communiste
républicain citoyen écologiste avait la
parole merci monsieur le Président et
Madame la prière ministre messieurs
évidemment les membres du gouvernement
chers collègues le 10 juillet 2018 lors
de l'examen du projet de loi liberté de
choisir son avenir professionnel ici
même notre groupe était intervenu à
l'article premier en émettant cette
critique je cite d'un compte personnel
de formation à bondé en heure nous
passons donc à un compte abondé en euros
si le nombre d'heures prises en charge
par le compte personnel de formation
diminue il est apparié que les
formations les plus longues et les plus
coûteuses devront faire l'objet d'un
financement complémentaire reposant
essentiellement sur le salarié fin de
citation dimanche à l'Assemblée
nationale on a adopté un amendement au
projet de loi de finance pour 2023 qui
prévoit de contraindre les salariés à
prendre en charge de 20 à 30% du coût
des formations nous avions donc raison
d'alerter il y a quatre ans sur les
risques de faire peser sur les salariés
le prix des formations professionnelles
c'est d'autant plus injuste qu'elle est
justifiée uniquement essentiellement par
un souci d'économie budgétaire qui est
décidément l'alpha et l'oméga de vos
choix budgétaires monsieur le ministre
ma question est double la subvention de
l'apprentissage a coûté 4 milliards
d'euros à l'État ce désengagement
organisé des entreprises au financement
de l'apprentissage vous amènent à
réduire le droit à la formation de fait
première question allez vous revenir sur
ces subventions indues qui opposent
formation professionnelle et continue et
salariés deuxième question allez enfin
accroître le contrôle des organismes de
formation qui accumulent une rente
générée par les coûts exorbitants des
formations proposées au détriment des
salariés de notre pays
pour vous répondre la parole est un
ministre délégué chargé de
l'enseignement et de la formation
professionnelle madame Grandjean vous
avez la parole merci
président
tu es le sénateur Boké j'ai écouté avec
attention ce que vous venez de dire à
l'intention du gouvernement et je crois
que c'est tout le contraire rendre le
système plus juste et plus efficace
combattre les fraudes régulariser les
dérives et toujours associé davantage la
formation un projet professionnel
d'avenir et notre ambition
je le rappelle le gouvernement a porté
ces derniers mois un certain nombre de
mesures pour améliorer la qualité de la
formation cela a conduit à éliminer
environ deux tiers des certifications
dans l'intérêt n'était pas avérées pour
l'évolution professionnelle de nos
concitoyens il a également conduit à
évincer des plateformes les organismes
de formation qui ne satisfaisaient pas
les exigences attendues par ailleurs
nous avons de PI octobre
débattus et adopté ensemble une loi
portez votre par votre collègue Martin
lévrier visant à lutter contre le
démarchage abusif et les fraudes il
s'agit à présent pour y parvenir de
faire en sorte que chaque bénéficiaire
s'engage de manière active dans sa
formation avec une participation
financière
mais nous voulons que ce soit juste
c'est pour cela que les demandeurs
d'emploi en seront dispensés tout comme
les salariés qui ont co-construit un
projet professionnel avec leur employeur
via un abonnement c'est sur ces bases
efficacité et équilibre que vont
s'ouvrir les concertations avec les
partenaires sociaux avec les
parlementaires avec les acteurs de la
formation pour déterminer le niveau de
cette participation et son plafonnement
convaincu que la formation est une clé
essentielle dans les parcours
professionnels cette responsabilité de
l'individu ne doit pas être un frein à
l'accès à la formation nous y serons
attentifs je vous remercie monsieur
oui madame le ministre votre réponse
n'est pas rassurante en 2018 le
directeur de Kennedy de votre ancienne
collègue Murielle Pénicaud disait au
partenaires sociaux qu'il n'y aurait pas
de problème de financement car les
cotisations patronales seraient
augmentées en conséquence s'il le
fallait en tout cas vous venez nous
expliquer que avec ce choix c'est la
première fois dans notre histoire
sociale que nos concitoyens vont devoir
financer eux-mêmes l'accès à un droit
qui
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à notre collègue André
gatelin pour le groupe du Rassemblement
des démocrates progressistes et
indépendants merci monsieur le Président
ma question s'adresse à Gérald Darmanin
ministre de l'Intérieur et des Outre-mer
monsieur le ministre l'ONG sevegard
Defenders qui offre pour la défense des
droits humains à l'échelle
internationale vient de publier un
rapport mettant en évidence l'existence
de 110 postes illégaux de police chinois
répartis sur plus de 50 pays poste qui
viserait à contrôler réprimer voire à
extrader hors de tout cadre légal des
citoyens chinois vers leur pays
d'origine l'accusation est grave elle
est très grave mais le rapport en
question est étayé par de très nombreux
documents et témoignages sur ces
pratiques illégales opérées hors du
territoire chinois en France ce sont
pour l'instant quatre postes illégaux de
ce type qui ont été dénombrer à Paris
Noisy-le-Grand et Aubervilliers
surveillance des établissements
taïwanais oui tibétains pression exercée
sur des citoyens chinois réfugiés en
France contrôle politique de la diaspor
à Brest la liste des activités illicites
dénoncées par l'ONG est longue interrogé
plusieurs responsables chinois ont
reconnu l'existence de ces postes en
arguant que ceux-ci se limiteraient à
des services d'assistance de type
consulaire auprès de leurs concitoyens
mais même sans autorisation de telles
activités sont de toute façon illégale
au regard du droit international au-delà
et si l'effet dénoncé par le NG sont
avérés ce serait sans conteste une
atteinte très grave à notre souveraineté
et même une forme toute nouvelle de
séparatisme opéré sur notre sol par des
agents illégaux d'une puissance
étrangère aujourd'hui tous les pays
européens concernés en soit en quête à
l'exception de la Grèce et d'Halloween
Hongrie ont déjà officiellement
diligentés une enquête sur ces pratiques
inquiétantes alors Monsieur le Ministre
avez-vous ou entendez-vous diligentés
une enquête de ce type en France je vous
remercie pour vous répondre la parole
est ministre de l'intérieur des
Outre-mer que Gérald Darmanin monsieur
le Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
secteurs monsieur le sénateur je veux
dire ici qu'effectivement la France ne
peut accepter en aucun cas des attentats
à sa souveraineté en temps lutter
extrêmement fortement contre les
influences étrangères sur son sol et
n'acceptera pas comme une pour accepter
dans le passé dans le futur que les
règles internationales notamment qui
prévoit l'accueil de ces ressortissants
des pays se fassent au détriment de
notre bonne relation entre État qui
s'agisse de la Chine et de tout autre
état
la DGSI et en effet à l'écoute de
révélation qui ont été pu être mise en
place par cette organisation non
gouvernementale elle a d'ailleurs
travaillé en amont bien évidemment de
ces révélations je lui ai demandé
d'accentuer évidemment son enquête de
renseignement auprès du Gouvernement de
la République et du président de la
République vous comprendrez que c'est
pas ici que je pourrais détailler ces
résultats mais si vous le permettez je
vous invite à vous rapprocher de la
délégation parlementaire au
renseignement qui elle est sous le saut
Confidentiel Défense pour que nous
donnions toutes les informations si le
président du Parlement Gérard Larcher ou
la présentation nationale ou la
délégation elle-même le président buffet
venait à demander ces informations ce
qui est certain c'est que pour tous les
pays extrêmement agressifs dans la
contre-influence sur notre sol le
président de la République voit la plus
de 4 ans a demandé des moyens renforcés
à la DGSI
l'occasion si vous le souhaitez dans le
cadre de la délégation renseignement de
pouvoir les détailler pour vous rassurer
que la France acceptera jamais ce genre
de pratique qui reste à confirmer pour
ce qui concerne les quatre postes qui
ont été évoqués par cette ONG en France
merci
la parole est à notre collègue Corinne
Imbert pour le groupe les républicains
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le Président ma question
s'adressait à madame la Première
ministre pourrait évoquer notre
souveraineté sanitaire car le sujet est
à la fois économique et sanitaire des
pénuries de médicaments et de
dispositifs médicaux cela fait des
années que ça dure mais aujourd'hui le
niveau des manquants a atteint des
sommets c'est du jamais vu paracétamol
et amoxicilline continuent de faire
l'actualité et le ministère impose quant
à lui des contingentements mais
aujourd'hui c'est aussi l'un des acteurs
mondiaux des industries de santé le
dernier fabricant français de poche de
perfusion pour les hôpitaux qui est en
redressement judiciaire et qui cherche à
repreneur et si aucun repreneur n'est
trouvé d'ici le 5 janvier alors
l'entreprise risque de fermer
définitivement les hôpitaux s'inquiètent
il n'est pas besoin de cela comment
demain pourront-ils s'approvisionner en
poche de perfusion
c'est un nouveau symbole de notre
indépendance sanitaire qui est en danger
comment expliquer cela Monsieur le
Ministre et que comptez-vous faire
[Applaudissements]
pour vous répondre la parole communiste
de la santé de la prévention Monsieur
François Braun
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs
les causes liées à ces pénuries de
médicaments sont multiples déjà la crise
covid augmente une modification de
prescription plus 13% par exemple pour
le paracétamol
il y a également des soucis sur le
principe actif et tout l'intérêt de
rapatrier ce principe actif en Europe et
en France dans le cadre du Plan France
2030 par exemple également des soucis de
production ou de distribution comme
c'est récemment le cas concernant le
doliprane pédiatrique qui est produit
essentiellement en Allemagne et avec un
mouvement social chez Sanofi qui
heureusement a pris fin récemment et qui
va nous permettre de retrouver nos
stocks cette situation vous le savez
n'est pas propre à la France elle
concerne l'ensemble du territoire
européen voire plus en ce qui concerne
l'amoxicilline c'est une pénurie au
niveau national lié à un défaut de
production notre système de surveillance
qui est porté par l'Agence nationale du
système de sécurité pardon du médicament
nous permet de choses nous permet déjà
d'être alerté très tôt puisque les
alertes arrivent lorsque nos stocks
diminuent en dessous de un mois pour la
plupart des produits donc ça veut pas
dire que nous n'en avons plus mais en
tout cas les stocks sont extrêmement bas
et elle nous permet aussi d'identifier
les causes ces causes nous permettant
d'avoir des actions ciblées en fonction
du médicament ces actions ciblées c'est
l'interdiction d'exporter pour les
grossistes lorsque les médicaments sont
en France c'est une distribution plus
équitable sur le territoire national via
la aussi des grossistes répartiteurs
c'est une prescription avec en officine
pharmaceutique la possibilité de donner
ce dont on a besoin voire même de
dégonder les boîtes
nous travaillons aussi avec les sociétés
scientifiques pour pouvoir travailler
sur les alternatives puisqu'il n'est pas
envisageable bien entendu que nous ne
puissions pas traiter l'ensemble des
Français et puis vous le savez France
2030 est le programme qui va nous
permettre de ramener en France les
productions ont tout du moins en Europe
pour faire de la France un produit un
produit un pays souverain en ce qui
concerne nos produits de santé pour cela
l'agence de l'innovation en santé a été
dotée d'un budget plus que conséquent
comme vous le savez je vous remercie
ce ministre merci pour votre réponse
mais vous n'avez répondu que sur les
pénuries de médicaments vous n'avez pas
abordé la question des difficultés de ce
fabricant français le dernier fabricant
français de poche de perfusion mais ces
révélateurs la pandémie a déjà révélé
que la fusion de l'établissement de
préparation et de réponse aux urgences
sanitaires avec d'autres agences pour
former publique santé publique France
vous avez fait perdre à l'époque toute
capacité d'anticipation d'une crise
sanitaire vous avez voulu une filière
française de masque cela risque de virer
à la déroute vouloir retrouver notre
indépendance sanitaire bien sûr
évidemment nous y sommes favorables
c'est nécessaire et indispensable
notamment dans le cadre du contexte
international mais commençons par ne pas
perdre celles qui nous reste c'est
l'exemple de ce fabricant de poche de
perfusion mais c'est aussi l'exemple de
l'Établissement français du sang qui
aujourd'hui est en difficulté et qui
mérite toute l'attention du gouvernement
estime sur le ministre des hôpitaux ont
une dinde vis-à-vis de l'Établissement
français du sang je ne veux pas que
notre système de santé soit sacrifié sur
le thème de berc mais si je vous vois
monsieur milite non je sais pas la tête
c'est la réalité ça a été confirmé ce
matin en audition par la commission des
affaires sociales les pénuries sont
insupportables et toutes paires de notre
indépendance sanitaire monsieur le
Président et merci pour le temps serait
inacceptable merci
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à notre collègue Corinne
Ferré pour le groupe socialiste
écologiste et républicain
monsieur le Président Madame la Ministre
pour répondre aux difficultés qu'il a
lui-même créé le gouvernement vient par
voie d'amendement au projet de loi de
finance 2023 d'instaurer un reste à
charge pour les salariés qui mobilisent
leur compte personnel de formation sur
le fond tout d'abord les Français qui
utiliseront leur CPF pour financer une
action de formation à nos compagnons
vers la VAE ou un bilan de compétences
se verront désormais impliquer une
franchise seul deux possibilités
d'exonération du ticket modérateurs sont
prévus en somme on est très très loin de
ce que vous nous survons nous survendiez
en 2018 avec la loi pour la liberté de
choisir son avenir professionnel lorsque
vous prétendiez je cite vouloir libérer
les salariés et leur offrir plus de
droits il faut le dire son est fini du
CPF dispositif construit par les
partenaires sociaux en vue de permettre
aux salariés d'établir leur parcours
professionnel votre mesure est
totalement injuste et viendra éloigner
encore plus de l'information les
salariés aux petites rémunérations et
qui sont souvent ceux qui ont le enfin
accès les mêmes que vous voulez faire
travailler jusqu'à 65 ans et donc faire
payer pour se former et rester dans
l'emploi quant à la forme on ne décide
pas comme ça un week-end en pleine nuit
de remettre en question la formation
professionnelle ceci à coup de 49-3 sans
avoir échangé avec les partenaires
sociaux alors que ces derniers vous ont
remis très récemment des propositions
concrètes madame la ministre vous
engagez-vous enfin à les écouter en vue
de mettre en oeuvre des mesures juste de
régulation du CPF qui permettent de
concilier équilibre financier et
développement des compétences
pour vous répondre la parole est à la
ministre déléguée en charge de
l'enseignement et de la formation
professionnelle un grand Jean
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs madame la
sénatrice de quoi s'agit-il il s'agit de
revenir à l'esprit du compte personnel
de formation d'abord en impliquant
davantage les bénéficiaires du compte
personnel de formation dans leur choix
de formation pour en faire un acte
réfléchi lié à un projet professionnel
cette disposition elle s'intègre dans
une logique globale je le disais tout à
l'heure elle est portée par le
gouvernement depuis plusieurs mois et
vise à corriger des dérives et des
fraudes relatives au système de
formation professionnelle des
dispositions dont le Parlement a déjà eu
à connaître et à débattre ont d'ailleurs
été adoptés pour cela nous nous sommes
également inspirés des propositions
faites dans votre propre rapport
concernant la soutenabilité Financière
de France compétences Corée du jeu avec
vos collègues Frédéric puissin et Martin
lévrier visant à mettre en place un
reste à charge au compte personnel de
formation pour ces raisons le
Gouvernement a déposé début novembre en
première lecture à l'Assemblée nationale
un amendement visant à mettre en place
mécanismes de régulation du compte
personnel de formation pour attendre la
fin des négociations avec les
partenaires sociaux vous l'avez modifié
au Sénat pour poser directement le
principe d'un reste à charge et le
Gouvernement a souhaité proposer en
seconde lecture un amendement
d'équilibre qui pose le principe de
participation du titulaire mais aussi
deux cas d'exonération pour les
demandeurs d'emploi et en cas
d'abondement par l'employeur dans les
formations qui sont proposées c'est donc
sur cette base aujourd'hui qui est
concertation vont s'engager avec les
partenaires sociaux les parlementaires
les acteurs de la formation pour
s'assurer que la participation de la
personne ne constituera pas une barrière
à la mobilisation des droits je vous
remercie
madame la sénatrice
madame le ministre je ne voudrais pas
être désagréable mais je sais très bien
ce qu'il y a dans notre rapport c'est
notorial et vous ne pouvez pas dire ce
que vous venez de dire est déformer nos
écrits non nous n'avons pas évidemment
et décidément les mêmes valeurs car pour
moi le dialogue social c'est la
concertation c'est l'écoute c'est
l'échange et les recherches de solutions
avec les partenaires sociaux une fois de
plus vous avez fait les choses sans eux
alors qu'ils ne sont pas opposés à des
mesures permettant d'améliorer le
système actuel où est la justice sociale
dans ce que vous imposez nulle part vous
ne voulez rien co-construire vous voulez
obliger les salariés à tirer un trait
sur leurs droits sociaux et à payer pour
se former
la parole est maintenant notre collègue
Isabelle Raymond pavéro pour le groupe
les républicains vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le Président Madame la
Ministre de l'Europe et des Affaires
étrangères depuis la mort de Massa mini
aux mains de la police des mœurs parce
qu'elles ne portait pas correctement son
voile le vendredi volte qu'il souffle
sur l'Iran ne faiblit pas et malgré la
férocité de la répression le cri femme
vie liberté résonne toujours plus fort
dans les rides du pays à ces trois mots
qui incarnent tout ce que la charia
tombe d'étouffer depuis 40 ans le régime
des molards réagit de la seule façon
qu'il connaisse par la brutalité la
terreur la reprise des pendaison
publique vient rappeler au monde la
barbarie à laquelle le pouvoir iranien
est prêt pour se maintenir en place les
témoignages poignants recueillis au
Sénat lors d'une conférence organisant
soutien au peuple iranien ont montré à
quel point la violence faisait partie de
la nature profonde de ce régime malgré
tout ils sont toujours aussi nombreux
femmes et hommes à continu de braver la
peur à lever pour briser les carcans
imposés par la Révolution islamique à se
battre pour des valeurs qui sont aussi
les nôtres et dont nous nous prétendons
régulièrement les défenseurs la France
comme l'Europe reste dans une forme de
retraite de moins en moins
compréhensible au condamnation de
principe et au message de solidarité
envers le peuple iranien n'ont ainsi
discrédidé que des sanctions d'une
surprenante faiblesse madame la ministre
concrètement quelles initiatives le
Gouvernement entend-il prendre pour
apporter un soutien en soulèvement
populaire iranien et pour accentuer la
pression internationale sur les
dignitaires du régime iranien
merci
pour vous répondre la parole que la
ministre de l'Europe des Affaires
étrangères madame Colonna
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs madame la
sénatrice vraiment pavéro oui le
mouvement de protestation en Iran se
poursuit la répression violente se
poursuit également avec
500 morts dont des dizaines d'enfants on
a vu aussi avec
horreur des premières exécutions et
lundi lundi les ministres des Affaires
étrangères des 27 pays de l'Union
européenne ont demandé l'arrêt immédiat
de ces exécutions
l'exécution de manifestants ne peut
tenir lieu de réponse aux aspirations de
la jeunesse c'est une évidence madame la
Première ministre l'a rappelé la France
continue d'agir de manière résolue il
n'y a aucun retrait aucun recul madame
la sénatrice un nouveau train de
sanction européenne a été adopté lundi
qui cible notamment la police des mœurs
impliquée dans la répression des
manifestations ainsi que la radiotéision
iranienne il ne peut y avoir d'impunité
pour les responsables des violations des
droits fondamentaux et vous savez que
c'est la quatrième fois que les
Européens cet automne adoptent des
sanctions contre l'Iran il continueront
si nécessaire
ils ont aussi adopté lundi
pardonnez-moi de nouvelles conclusions
du Conseil très complètes sur l'Iran qui
constitue un cadre d'action d'une grande
fermeté par ailleurs face à la politique
qui est actuellement menée par la
République islamique d'Iran et nous
utiliserons pleinement ce cadre madame
le Premier ministre vous l'a indiqué
par ailleurs la France votera en faveur
du projet de texte portant exclusion de
l'Iran de la Commission des droits de
l'homme des droits de la femme dont font
partie
qui font partie des droits de l'homme
comme chacun le sait aux Nations Unies
je l'avais indiqué en audition à la
commission des affaires étrangères de
l'Assemblée nationale la semaine
dernière et je vous le confirme la
France votre en faveur de ce texte
j'ajoute que celui-ci devrait être
adopté aujourd'hui même le loyer nous
continuons d'agir en soutenant
résolument cette pulsion de vie qui se
manifeste en Iran je remercie
merci Madame Raymond pavéro quelques
secondes madame la ministre l'Iran
efface un tournant de son histoire la
France l'Europe la communauté
internationale doivent se mobiliser il
est temps qu'elle se montre à la hauteur
du courage des manifestants iraniens
notre pays fidèle à son histoire et à
ses valeurs doit être à l'avant-garde
c'est ce que nous ont demandé au Sénat
les résistants iraniens
merci
la parole est au président Laurent
Lafont pour le groupe de l'Union
centriste merci
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre de l'Intérieur il y a quelques
semaines vous annonciez ici même au
Sénat que des festivals devront être
annulés durant l'été 2024 à cause des
Jeux Olympiques cette annonce a provoqué
de nombreuses réactions
d'incompréhension la semaine dernière
avec plus d'une trentaine de sénateurs
et sénatrice membre de la commission
culture éducation et communication du
Sénat nous avons publié dans le journal
Le Monde une tribune pour dire que le JO
ne peuvent se faire au détriment des
nombreuses manifestations sportives
culturelles festives qui ont lieu
traditionnellement partout en France
madame la ministre de la Culture a dans
un interview publiée aujourd'hui dans le
journal Le Parisien précisé que des
solutions avaient été trouvées
pratiquement avec les tous les grands
festivals en tout cas ceux qui recourent
aux unités de force mobile tant mieux
néanmoins de nombreuses questions
demeure quid des grands événements
festifs qui ont lieu dans un certain
nombre de régions françaises durant
l'été je pense en particulier au
sud-ouest de la France avec des fêtes
comme celle de Bayonne ou de dates quid
de la surveillance des plages qui
jusqu'à présent sont assurés par des CRS
quides enfin des nombreux événements qui
pour se tenir ont besoin des de recourir
aux sociétés de sécurité privée on le
sait les JO vont massivement faire appel
à ces sociétés plus de 15
poste doivent être créés pour faire face
au seul besoin des Jeux Olympiques ces
sociétés pourront-elles couvrir à la
fois les besoins des événements en
province et ce lier aux Jeux olympiques
et dans ces conditions monsieur le
ministre pourquoi ne pas compléter le
dispositif en recourant à l'armée
pour vous répondre la parole est au
ministre de l'Intérieur monsieur Gérard
Darmanin oui monsieur président monsieur
le Président Lafont les Jeux Olympiques
à Paris c'est une fois par siècle
et les Jeux Olympiques à Paris avec une
cérémonie d'ouverture en dehors d'un
stade c'est une fois tous les 3000 ans
parce que personne ne l'a jamais
organisé en dehors d'un stade et je
pense que l'on peut constater ensemble
l'intérêt général qui est de réussir je
vous en ai particulièrement sensible je
le sais les Jeux olympiques de Paris et
les Jeux paralympiques qui s'étale
durant l'été 2024 je serai d'ailleurs
qu'en 2024 c'est aussi le 80e
anniversaire du débarquement de
Normandie ce qu'il y a qu'au mois de
juin également il y aura énormément de
force des forces sécurité intérieure
pour protéger l'ensemble de ces grands
événements avec tous ces chefs d'État et
bien sûr cette grande familiature à
Paris ce que vous en proposez avec la
ministre de la Culture avec la ministre
des Sports en charge des Jeux Olympiques
ce n'est pas l'annulation des événements
c'est leur décalage notamment dans le
temps et je crois que nous avons été en
partie entendu
par exemple le Tour de France qui ne va
pas arriver en 2024 à Paris et le 28
juillet mais à Nice le 21 juillet voilà
quelque chose qui nous paraît conforme à
l'intérêt général et conforme à la
volonté d'avoir évidemment un tour de
France en 2024 ou le festival des
Vieilles Charrues je peux aussi parler
du Festival d'Avignon et d'autres grands
festivals dont madame la ministre de la
Culture à l'occasion d'évoquer un
décalage de dates pour les Vieilles
Charrues elle se déroulant du 11 au 14
juillet au lieu du 18 au 21 juillet
comme quoi il est on est capable dans
notre pays de discuter en constatation
avec tous les acteurs du monde sportif
et culturel au niveau de festif en
général pour que ces événements se
tiennent mais dans des conditions où on
doit comprendre qu'il faut 45000
policiers et gendarmes pour les Jeux
Olympiques de Paris de sa série
d'ouverture jusqu'à sa fin en ce qui
concerne l'armée elle est déjà très
largement mobilisée si l'armée ne tenait
pas par exemple le site qui ferait
partir les bateaux sur la barre je serai
30 ufm que nous serons obligés
d'utiliser par les forces de l'ordre
l'armée c'est aussi ceux qui gardent la
politique aérienne se autorité de la
première ministre les lutte antidrone ou
contre l'arrivée de d'avion par exemple
au-dessus de nos événements mais l'armée
n'est pas fait pour les matières de
l'ordre voilà plus d'un siècle que nous
avons spécialisé cela grâce à un certain
nombre de policiers et de gendarmes ce
n'est pas pour les confier à la va-vite
il faut conclure à des militaires on
aura l'occasion d'en parler la sécurité
privée on est en fait le ministre de du
travail un certain nombre de démarches
très positif qui nous permet d'être
confiant dans la présence de la sécurité
privée partout sur le territoire
national sur le président Lafont
merci Monsieur ministre pour ces
éléments de réponse
n'avons pas forcément compris la façon
dont la question des festivals avait été
abordée jusqu'à présent vous faites une
annonce et quelques semaines après on
nous annonce que finalement les
solutions étaient trouvées dont acte
étant mieux mais pour éviter que ces
solutions ne se reproduisent nous
souhaiterions notamment que au niveau
des territoires et avec les élus locaux
nous fassiez un inventaire précis des
manifestations et que vous abordiez
concrètement quelles solutions peuvent
être trouvées dans un contexte on le
sait et vous l'avez rappelé qui est
exceptionnel avec les difficultés que
peuvent engendrer l'organisation d'une
manifestations aussi importante que
celle des JO néanmoins le dialogue avec
les élus locaux sur ce point nous sommes
extrêmement importants merci la parole
est à notre collègue Béatrice Gosselin
pour le groupe les républicain
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
Président mes chers collègues mieux chez
moi mieux pour ma planète voici le
slogan qui présente ma prime rénove aide
au financement des travaux de rénovation
énergétique calculez en fonction des
revenus et du gain écologique des
travaux travaux principalement
d'isolation et de chauffage qui doivent
être effectués par des entreprises
labellisées RGE lorsque votre logement
est mal isolé ou équipé d'un mode de
chauffage dont le coût augmente de façon
exponentielle vous êtes évidemment
intéressé par ce dispositif quand vous
cliquez sur le site vous lisez une aide
accessible à tous propriétaires ou
copropriétaires
occupant ou bailleurs qui s'adapte à la
situation de chacun et favorise des
rénovations ambitieuses cela paraît
simple et attractif si dans de nombreux
cas pardon les démarches aboutissent et
les primes sont versées dans un délai
raisonnable certains dossiers
connaissent des difficultés importantes
et les aides arrivent tardivement
jusqu'à 10 mois après les travaux
numéro national 08 injoignable
difficulté pour accéder à l'interface
dossier accepté dans un premier temps
puis refuser pour l'usager ces 15 jours
maximum pour compléter ou corriger un
dossier mais des semaines sans réponse
de la part du service ma prime rénale
ainsi de nombreuses personnes se
trouvent en difficulté financière quand
les travaux sont à payer et que l'aide
notifié par l'État se fait attendre
c'est aussi le cas de d'entreprises ou
d'artisans RGE qui remplissent les
dossiers pour leurs clients et qui
attendent longtemps les paiements des
primes fragilisant ainsi leur trésorerie
même des référents préfecture ont des
difficultés à avoir des retours des
dossiers en souffrance alors monsieur le
ministre que comptez-vous faire pour
améliorer ce dispositif et ne pas mettre
particulier et entreprises en difficulté
pour vous répondre la parole à Olivier
Klein mélise délégué en charge de la
ville et du logement sur le ministre
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs madame la
sénatrice Gosselin vous avez raison il
existe un certain nombre de
dysfonctionnement mais je crois d'abord
qu'il ne doivent pas masquer les 1,5
millions de chantier qui ont été
réalisés dans le cadre de ma prime
rénove 1,5 millions de chantiers qui ont
été en particulier aidé 80% de ménage
modestes et quand on interroge les
ménages 66% des ménages qui ont fait ces
travaux n'auraient pas fait ces travaux
sans ma prime rénove néanmoins oui des
difficultés existent un certain nombre
d'irrégularités voire de fraude ont été
constatés et ça nous a obligé dans la
volonté du gouvernement d'être très
attentif à ces fraude de prendre un peu
plus de temps sur l'évaluation des
dossiers mais je peux vous assurer que
tous les services de la NAS sont
extrêmement mobilisés pour régler ces
différentes difficultés prendre des
contacts individuels avec les familles
dans lesquelles les dossiers prennent
trop de temps j'étais avant-hier je
crois en rendez-vous avec la déf des
droits et nous avons évoqué un certain
nombre de cas qui lui avait été remonté
nous travaillons d'arrache-pied pour
régler ses problèmes c'est tout le sens
de ce grand service public qui est
France Renov que nous allons faire
progresser que nous allons faire
améliorer en termes de performance parce
que oui un certain nombre de nombreux
travaux ont déjà été réalisés mais il
faut aller plus loin dans la performance
et dans des travaux globaux aller plus
loin dans les travaux dans les
copropriétés dans l'habitat collectif
parce que c'est oui vous avez raison
comme c'est indiqué sur le site le
chantier du siècle et je peux vous
assurer de la détermination de mon
ministère du gouvernement et de la
première ministre sur ce dossier merci
j'entends bien monsieur le ministre mais
il est vrai que certains entreprises
rencontrent des difficultés de
trésorerie quand elles ont 15 20 000
euros pour des petites entreprises c'est
beaucoup et je pense que Lana qui est
l'interrupteur pourrait entrer dans le
dispositif du bouquet de France service
qui permettrait à des habitants de
pouvoir avoir une réponse rapide et
efficace merci merci
non monsieur le ministre je suis désolé
on ne fait pas de commentaires sur le
commentaire ici alors je donne la parole
maintenant à
notre collègue Jean-Jacques le sac pour
le groupe socialiste écologiste et
républicain
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le Président ma question
s'adresse au ministre de la transition
écologique et la cohésion des
territoires et porte sur la mise en
œuvre de 0 artificialisation nette à
l'horizon 2050 et sur la réduction de
moitié d'ici à 2030 du rythme de
consommation des espaces naturels
agricoles et forestiers sinon de
contestons pas les objectifs de sobriété
foncières et de préservation
environnementale de cette réforme
structurante pour nos territoires des
points de crispation demeure portant à
la fois sur la méthode employée
largement descendante et sur le fond des
dispositifs cette première étape du zan
s'est opérée dans la plus grande
confusion générant incompréhension et
inquiétude chez beaucoup d'élus le Sénas
est à nouveau saisi de cette
problématique en lançant une mission
conjointe de contrôle la proposition de
loi issue de ces travaux doit permettre
une évolution rapide du cadre juridique
du zan et dans son déploiement de temps
de vers davantage de discernement de
pragmatisme et de bon sens nous
attendons ainsi gouvernement des
engagements clairs sur la temporalité
avec la révision du calendrier des
modifications des documents de
planification sur la gouvernance une
grande partie des élus demeure écartées
des négociations ce qui est inadmissible
je rappelle que de nombreux départements
restent totalement ou partiellement
dépourvu de Scott chez Mad cohérence
territoriale d'où l'absent en délus les
gens à la Conférence régionale des
stradettes il faut renforcer la
concertation entre région Scott et bloc
communale en dotant le zan d'une
gouvernance plurielle partagée et
décentralisée sur la différenciation en
garantissant la prise en compte des
particularités du monde rural et les
spécificités territoriales et fort passé
projet développement local spécificité
des hommes littorales et de montagne
pour préserver le droit à construire des
communes rurales ne faut-il pas laisser
la libre appréciation de leurs élus une
surface minimale garantie par le Scott
enfin la logique d'usage étant celle
d'une densification de que pensez-vous
de l'opportunité de lancer un programme
national et complémentaire de
réhabilitation du bâti ancien en centre
bourg
pour vous répondre la parole est à
Monsieur Christophe Béchu mini de la
transition du écologique de la cohésion
des territoires c'est le ministre
monsieur président mesdames messieurs
les sénateurs monsieur le sénateur le
Zac
je pense qu'entre la première question
au gouvernement à laquelle je l'honneur
de répondre dans cette émission sur le
zan au mois de juillet et aujourd'hui je
dois être rendu à presque une trentaine
d'heures d'échanges avec la chambre
haute sur le sujet et la dernière en
date à l'invitation de la présidente
Valérie Letard juste avant que la
présentation de la PPL est lieu
aujourd'hui
j'ai eu l'occasion de rencontrer
plusieurs groupes nous avons même
échangé ensemble il y a peu de temps sur
le sujet j'ai rencontré les associations
d'élus et j'attends dans les milieux qui
viennent la fumée blanche du texte que
le Sénat va proposer pour faire en sorte
d'amander le dispositif dans l'esprit
d'ouverture que le gouvernement a
indiqué depuis le début du mois d'août
quand il a suspendu la mise en oeuvre
des décrets de la fin du mois d'avril je
vous rappelle les étapes qui sont calées
pour ceux qui relèvent du pouvoir
réglementaire la réécriture des décrets
est prévue pour le début de l'année
prochaine nous avons fait travailler les
agents d'urbanisme et les associations
de mer pour déterminer la granularité la
manière d'aller écrire ce qui relève des
espaces naturels et agricoles la
première ministre a eu des mots
extrêmement clairs en clôture du Salon
des mers à la fois sur les grands
projets d'envergure national et sur la
garantie rurale ce qui nous importe
c'est d'abord de rappeler et je ne doute
pas compte tenu de vos propos que tous
nous sommes convaincus de la nécessité
de la sobriété foncière
[Musique]
la parole est à notre collègue Marc
Lamini pour le groupe les républicains
merci
merci monsieur le président madame la
Première ministre mesdames et messieurs
les ministres chers collègues ma
question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre délégué chargé des transports
et concernant le volet ferroviaire et
l'ensemble aussi des personnels le 14
novembre dernier vers 19h dans les
Ardennes Donchery commune d'un peu plus
de 2000 habitants situés sur la ligne
SNCF Charleville-Mézières Sedan un père
de famille et sa fille ont été tués
happées par un train de marchandises ont
descendant d'un TER qui dessert cette
gare ce drame qui a suscité beaucoup
d'émotions dans ce boursontre et dans
les Ardennes mais en évidence les
problèmes de sécurité cette gare située
sur l'axe calebal double voie électrifié
n'est pas équipé de passage souterrains
demande formulée de longue date par le
maire et ses collègues ni de passage
supérieur seul des pictogrammes indique
la présence d'un train croiseur pour les
voyageurs à noter que cette gare est
utilisée aussi par des travailleurs qui
font partie d'une section
sur l'ensemble du réseau national plus
de 900 traversées de voies
pour piétons existe monsieur le ministre
quelle mesure envisagez-vous pour la
sécurité des usé et surtout en parlant
de moyens humains renforcés les moyens
humains de présence dans les gars TER
notamment et présence indispensable des
contrôleurs parce que là malheureusement
il y avait pas de contrôleurs ainsi que
dans les gars je vous remercie pour vous
répondre la parole est comme ils disent
déléguée charger les transports
monsieur le Président et mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur à la mini je vais d'abord
m'associer à l'émotion que vous avez
relayée dans l'hémicycle après le drame
de Donchery il y a quelques jours qui a
emporté la mort de deux personnes et je
tiens à vous indiquer que même si nous
n'avons pas encore l'ensemble des
éléments sur les causes et conditions de
ce drame le bureau enquête analyse dans
sa section chargée de transport
terrestre a ouvert à ma demande une
enquête et tous les éléments seront
évidemment communiqués le plus
rapidement possible après l'ensemble des
investigations nécessaires cela pose la
question d'un certain nombre
d'aménagements d'informations de
formation qui doivent être renforcées au
sein de la SNCF notamment dans des
petites gares ou des haltes comme
c'était le cas en l'espèce j'ai demandé
en effet au président de la SNCF au PDG
de SNCF voyageurs de prévoir un ensemble
d'actions renforcées au-delà de ce qui a
déjà été engagé depuis maintenant trois
ans sur la signalisation sur
l'information hangar sur la formation
des conducteurs sur les points de danger
particulier en termes de visibilité ou
de difficultés de je suis prêt à
regarder le dossier de bon chérie
spécifiquement avec vous mais
malheureusement c'est quelques centaines
de lieux qui sont concernés encore en
France aujourd'hui nous avons fait un
travail engagé par Elisabeth devant
lorsqu'elle était ministre chargé des
transports pour aménager un certain le
passage à niveau mais la question a
notamment dans les haltes ferroviaires
d'un certain nombre d'aménagements de
formation et d'informations doivent être
renforcés je suis prêt à y travailler
avec le Sénat avec vous en particulier
je connais votre engagement au-delà de
ce drame sur la question ferroviaire je
me tiens donc à votre disposition
monsieur la Mini
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre merci pour ces informations et
surtout une solidarité puisque je crois
que c'est réellement important bon c'est
vrai que le cheval de bataille de
beaucoup d'eau de nos collègues
également que je partage sur tous les
bancs c'est aussi les moyens humains
parce que les moyens humains sont
réellement indispensables s'il y avait
eu un contrôleur je pense que ce drame
aurait été évité j'ai aussi en mémoire
deux drames qui ont été évités grâce
aussi aux personnel et au conducteur un
train qui déraille à cause d'un convoi
exceptionnel et puis un TER qui avait
heurté aussi quelques années un convoi
exceptionnel donc merci sincèrement puis
c'est surtout c'est un combat collectif
merci
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à notre collègue Olivier
Hainaut pour le groupe de l'Union
centriste
merci monsieur le président madame la
Première ministre mesdames messieurs les
ministres chers collègues ma question
concerne les ZFE zone un faible émission
une idée séduisante une idée européenne
séduisante mais dans l'application est
particulièrement complexe et j'y vois
une incohérence environnementale une
injustice sociale une fracture
territoriale voire générationnelle et un
choix industriel incertain une
incohérence environnementale faire peser
sur le sol citoyen automobiliste la
responsabilité du réchauffement
climatique ou des particules dans les
villes m'apparaît excessif il faudra pas
longtemps avant qu'on dise que le
responsable du réchauffement climatique
c'est la mobylette de l'ouvrier
l'injustice sociale et bien ce sont les
plus modestes qui sont impactés il
suffit d'aller dans les quartiers pour
constater que vous voyez des véhicules
dans les quartiers de gens modeste des
véhicules d'alvinet 5 des vignettes 4
une fracture territoriale voire de
générationnelle et bien ce sont les
habitants des campagnes ceux de la
ruralité du périurbain ainsi un couple
de retraités qui a une clio diesel
depuis plusieurs années ne peut plus
aller voir ses enfants en ville et enfin
un choix industriel incertain
l'industrie automobile européenne n'est
pas prête à cette mutation vers le
véhicule électrique aussi rapidement il
y a 30% de de cette industrie qui est
qui est en danger et donc ma question
concerne votre vision des aide et fe
quelle application et quelles
conséquences sur Vinci pour vous
répondre la parole est au ministre
délégué chargé les transports monsieur
Clément beau nous avait la parole
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur Hainaut permettez-moi de
revenir d'un mot rapide sur l'objectif
des zones affaiblissement parce qu'elles
ne sont pas en soi une volonté
évidemment d'exclure de priver d'excès
au centre urbain toute une partie de la
population elles viennent d'une
nécessité constater et votée par le
Parlement dans deux textes législatifs
il y a quelques années la loi
d'orientation des mobilités la loi
climat résilience qui vise à mettre en
place progressivement j'insiste sur ce
point dans 43 métropoles françaises de
plus de 150 000 habitants des zones en
laissant une très grande flexibilité aux
collectivités locales concernent c'est
un outil entre les mains des
collectivités locales concernées qui
doit être adaptée à la réalité de
chacune de ces métropoles et ses
agglomérations le calendrier n'est pas
prédéfini sauf pour les métropoles qui
sont en dépassement de normes de qualité
de l'air nous faisons ça précisément
pour réduire les impacts sur les
qualités sur la qualité de l'air et pour
à l'améliorer et pour éviter les plus de
45 000 morts chaque année constaté à
cette pollution c'est cela l'objectif en
laissant cette règle cette flexibilité
s'étend aussi au type de modalités de
circulation d'accès qui sont qui sont
décidés pardon par chacune de ces
collectivités avec une grande
différenciation qui sera précisé et
définie par chacune des métropoles le
rôle de l'État c'est d'être en
accompagnement pour que précisément les
risques que vous identifiez à juste
titre
socio-générationnels territoriaux ne se
réalisent pas et c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous avons déployé
progressivement en lien avec les
métropoles des aides pour que la mise en
place progressive des et des feux se
fasse le mieux possible les ailes c'est
notamment l'acquisition le véhicule le
bonus écologique la prime à la
conversion nous avons décidé dans le
projet de loi de finances pour 2023
soumis au scénar et l'assemblée
d'augmenter à 7000 euros le bonus pour
les ménages les plus modestes nous avons
aussi c'était une idée de plusieurs
sénatrices et sénateurs d'expérimenter
une un prêt à taux zéro dans deux zones
affaiblissions et deux métropoles
aujourd'hui nous sommes prêts à
l'étendre et en regardait les modalités
avec vous dans les prochains mois donc
nous devrons évidemment renforcer encore
nos accomp travailler avec les
métropoles mais je le dis la flexibilité
du dispositif est entre les mains des
collectivités pour que ça se passe le
mieux possible dans le calendrier le
plus adapté possible
monsieur Hainaut oui merci monsieur le
ministre je ne doute pas évidemment de
votre bonne foi et de votre bonne
volonté mais ceci dit trois observations
il faudra pas longtemps avant que les
aides et feux deviennent des zones à
forte exclusion
je pense aussi que il y a dans cette
écologie culpabilisante il y a une
obsession de la comme plutôt qu'un souci
du bien public et puis aussi un mépris
social c'est quand même la France des
clopes et du diesel qu'on regarde encore
de haut et il y a dans tout ça un germe
de gilets jaunes je vous remercie
merci
mes chers collègues madame la Première
ministre mesdames et messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues j'ai le
plaisir de saluer la présence de la
tribune de l'honneur d'une délégation de
six parlementaire de la Chambre des
conseillers du Royaume du Maroc présidée
par le docteur Mohammed zidou président
du groupe d'amitié
[Applaudissements]
président du groupe d'amitié Maroc
France à la Chambre des conseillers
notre collègue Christian Corbon
président du groupe d'amitié est présent
à leur côté lors de l'entretien que nous
avons eu en fin de matinée nous avons
évoqué les principales étapes de leur
séjour ici à Paris et en Normandie qui
leur permettront de s'entretenir avec le
ministre Olivier belge d'ailleurs d'un
déplacement au Maroc madame la ministre
de Madame la Ministre de l'Europe et des
Affaires étrangères il devrait ensuite
découvrir les travaux de recherche
développement menés par EDF en matière
nucléaire et d'énergie renouvelable et
visiter les chantiers naval à Cherbourg
cet accueil témoigne de la relation
privilégiée qui nous lie au Royaume du
Maroc et à sa chambre des conseillers et
de notre attachement à une amitié
ancienne qui dans cette dimension
parlementaire
qui s'exprime avec une force
particulière même lorsque quelques
tensions a pu apparaître dans la
relation bilatérale nous avons su garder
intacte cette capacité d'écouter de
dialogue qui est la marque des amitiés
sincères le jumelage en cours entre le
assemblées et aussi le Sénat italien le
dynamisme des relations entre nos
groupes d'amitié respectifs semblent une
parfaite illustration madame la Première
ministre mesdames et messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues
permettez-moi de souhaiter à nos amis
membres de la Chambre des conseillers du
Maroc la plus cordiale bienvenue au
Sénat de la République française
[Applaudissements]
nous en avons terminé mes chers
collègues avec les questions au
Gouvernement
nous nous retrouverons pour les
questions gouvernement début d'année
avec bonheur ce qui me permet de
souhaiter à chacune et à chacun
d'excellentes fêtes de fin d'année à
remercier les collègues les ministres
mais ça n'est pas terminé puisque
16h35 nous reprenons pour l'examen d'une
Commission Mixte Paritaire la séance est
donc suspendue